[Musik]
vor genau zwei Jahren habe ich den San
Sebastian Cheesecake gebacken und damit
die Cheesecake Welt auf den Kopf
gestellt ich bin unendlich dankbar dass
so viele Menschen jedes Wochenende mein
San Sebastian Cheesecake nachbacken für
mich ist das eines der leckersten
Cheesecakes der Welt gleichzeitig ist
die Zubereitung auch die einfachste der
Welt ihr müsst lediglich die Zutaten die
ich euch in die Kommentare schreibe
zusammenrühren wichtig ist dass man
wirklich nur so lange wie notwendig wird
und nicht zu lange wir wollen keine Luft
reinschlagen sondern die Masse super
schön cremig haben auch wichtig ist dass
man beim Vanille nicht spart falls ihr
kein Vanilleextrakt habt dann nehmt
gerne eine richtige Vanilleschote eine
auslaufsichere Springform schützt
einfach vor Frustration und dass euch
das ganze ausläuft und noch viel
wichtiger ist eure Backzeit jeder
Backofen backt anders und es kommt
wirklich auf jede Minute an genauso muss
ein Zahn Sebastian Cheesecake aussehen
und am besten schmeckt er mir mit ein
bisschen voll die Schokolade
[Musik]